I am trying to lose weight because I
just moved out to this horrendous city
and LA is an awful awful place if you
think it's okay you're a bad person
[Laughter]
but I'm trying to lose weight really
[__] I bought a Girl Scout cookies
I love Girl Scout cookies so much always
delicious but all the names of the
cookie sound like racial slurs this town
was nice to all these friggin Samoas
moved in god damn Thin Mints running
everything on you like this place what
are you a Savannah Smiles funny names
that's the point
[Music]
it's like my other favorite funny names
are the names of the drinks in organic
juice bars go to an organic juice bar
all the drink names sound like the most
disgusting sex positions you could ever
do I totally gave this chick the berry
burst class
[Applause]
you know what the berry burst is just
like the fiber flush except not in the
butt food bits I like to eat out I don't
like ramen restaurants that much I'm
just I don't want anybody asking me to
get it anymore for dinner
ramen I want to go get ramen I'm gonna
get ramen for dinner when I go to the
ramen place get ramen that [__] I used
to eat in college no I don't want to go
to a restaurant and pay for that come on
this is the good ramen it's the real
ramen that's what they always say
that's like me being like hey hey guys
guys
want to go to the Swanson hungry man
dinner restaurant no guys this is the
real Salsbury steak it's the good kind
I'll take it
love food I love it fast food that's my
favorite
I don't like slow cooking I like fast
food Taco Bell that's my favorite food
probably it's up there it's way up at
the top of the list here's the thing
there's a true Taco Bell story I'm gonna
tell you I get Taco Bell after shows a
lot when I'm on the road 1:00 a.m.
fourth meal time okay
this happened to me somewhere in the
country I was on the road I did a show
went to talk about 1:00 a.m. I'm pulling
into the parking lot and I realized as
I'm pulling in I'm not hungry yet that's
a problem I can't go back to the hotel
then wait till I get hungry then go out
to get to talk of it now I'm lazy I got
to do this in one trip all right I got
to get the Taco Bell on the way to the
hotel
get to the hotel go directly to the room
climb right into my bed and then I eat
it laying on my side Cleopatra style
looking at Netflix like amuse me gordita
[Applause]
so here's my solution this is what I
come up with I'm like oh I know what
I'll do I'll just sit in my car in the
parking lot until I'm hungry enough to
hit the drive-thru that's not what it
looks like you're doing it's one o'clock
in the morning it looks like I'm waiting
for my heroin dealer to show up or this
is the place where I meet the men that I
cheat on my wife with
I believe in that punchline so I'm just
sitting there in my car and it looks
weird I'm sitting there for so long that
eventually the Taco Bell manager notices
me and he comes to the window and he
starts looking at me like this this is
not a good look that look and I see him
and I panic cuz I'm like he's gonna call
the cops on me right now and I freaked
out and I just hit the gas and peel out
but here's the funny part
I don't peel out of the parking lot as
to get out of the embarrassing situation
I just gunned it right into the
drive-through
[Applause]
[Music]